i decided to move into home goods you
moved into a home
goods i did what i only put things
in this room that catch my eye
you see what i'm doing uh living in a
store
so fun we teamed up with jillian and
home goods for a behind the scenes look
at their new six
episode comedy home sweet home goods
streaming now
on youtube home sweet home goods is a
new online
comedy series from home goods where i
basically make myself
way too at home at home goods and i'm
doing everything from working from home
to entertaining friends and occasionally
having some awkward dates
you really just go get to have a great
time and do these episodes and have
fun the funniest thing is the day after
we rapped
me and my friend charlotte who was
actually in the series playing a home
goods employee
came back that later that morning and
chopped anyone who comes near it i get
very protective
no not my sofa it's the only thing i
have this series
basically shows why people are so
obsessed with home goods you know it's
so
fun and creative and it just makes you
feel like you can be
your own designer and i think that's
what i loved about it